the record long government shutdown is
now in its 29th day president Trump says
he will make what he called on Twitter a
major announcement this afternoon it is
on the shutdown and the southern border
the White House did not give any details
of what he might announce but mr. Trump
is not expected to declare a national
emergency
this comes as special counsel Robert
Muller's office disputed the accuracy of
a published report that the president
directed his former lawyer to lie to
Congress
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the details Errol good morning good
morning you're right the special
counsel's office issued this rare public
statement denying a BuzzFeed news story
which claimed president Trump encouraged
his former fixer and lawyer Michael
Cohen to lie to congressional
investigators now that was reportedly an
effort to downplay the president's role
in negotiations to erect a Trump Tower
in Moscow
the spokesman for the Special Counsel
released this statement Friday night
quote BuzzFeed's description of specific
statements to the special counsel's
office and characterization of documents
and testimony obtained by this office
regarding Michael Cohen's congressional
testimony are not accurate BuzzFeed news
cited two unnamed federal law
enforcement officials who asserted that
mullahs team collected emails text and
testimony to support the charges which
if true meant the president had most
likely committed a crime yesterday the
news had congressional Democrats openly
discussing the possibility of
impeachment House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff tweeted quote the
allegation that the President of the
United States may have suborned perjury
before our committee in an effort to
curtail the investigation and cover-up
his business dealings with Russia is
among the most serious to date we will
do what's necessary to find out if it's
true White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders vigorously denied the story
that's absolutely ridiculous I think
that the president's outside counsel
addressed this best and said in a
statement earlier today those
categorically false Trump attorney Rudy
Giuliani called Cohen a criminal and a
liar saying if you believe Cohen
I can get you a great deal on the
Brooklyn Bridge President Trump said
Cohen was lying to reduce his jail time
and to watch his father-in-law Cohen
advisor Lanny Davis said that tweet was
a threat to the Cohen family the
president United States in trying to
intimidate a witness that is trying to
tell the truth and called him a rat for
telling the truth that sounds like a
mafioso Don it creates fear in the
family of Michael Kohn now what's
interesting is BuzzFeed news says they
stand behind and remain confident in the
accuracy of their report they go on to
say that they will continue to report
this and they want to determine what
specifically the special counsel is
disputing Anthony Errol Barnett thanks
Errol